As far as we are
concerned, HTTP/2
works the exact same
way HTTP/1 does.
What changes is the
performance and the precautions
you have to take.
You could start building a
web app with HTTP/2 in mind
since the number of browsers
that don't support HTTP/2
is getting smaller and smaller.
If you're running
your own server
or trying to figure out where
to host your web yourself,
make sure to enable
HTTP/2 there too.
For more information
on how to do that,
there's a link in the
notes with instructions
for the most common service
providers and servers.
In the next lesson,
we'll take a look
at more security measures
like cross-origin resource
sharing, same-origin policy,
and cross-site scripting.
You might even get the chance
to do some hacking yourself.